[Music]
so guys I got something but we're in the
theme of baseball here so I just want to
I just wanna it's not often I say nice
things about the human species just as
an organism it's not often I do because
you know because we don't deserve it but
if you compare this to the rest of the
animal kingdom if you had an all animal
Olympics there's not a single event we
would win I'm just saying so true maybe
the shooting all right or whatever that
but how about complaining complaining
maybe we'll win that yeah but running
jumping you know lifting all of this I
don't think we would we uh but so here's
something we're really good at and
you almost you don't need much training
at it sitting on the couch eating potato
chips that's one that's one another one
is
if you see a projectile
in the air
and you want to catch it
and you run
at just the right speed so that you are
where the projectile lands
in your myth when you arrive
okay this is an extraordinary feat that
I don't think we give ourselves enough
credit for oh I disagree we give
ourselves tons of credit for that
because there are guys that we pay
millions of dollars that's true to do
just that Millions
[Laughter]
but you don't have to be a million
dollar player to be able to catch a ball
in the Outfield I know but you you just
have to have such a hand-eye
coordination you have to have it an
extra kind of sense sometimes because
you do see some people this is my point
I'm saying coordinated completely extra
sense yeah is common in our species
that's all I'm saying that's it's why
you have like weekend softball games
with middle-aged men okay where they can
still catch the ball running in the
Outfield and they were never
professional you have little league and
pony league and and and double a triple
A and the majors everybody it's softball
everybody can run and be where the ball
is when it lands and if they miss it
it's because they they weren't fast
enough not because if they were fast
enough they would have still missed it
okay
so I'm just trying to tell you that you
can solve this mathematically and we do
this in physics 101 where you have a
projectile and its Arc is well
approximated by a parabola which is a
particular shape that things will take
um when they're in free uh under the
influence of gravity and only gravity
and it comes close it's not the exact
shape it's close enough for almost any
purpose that we have here and so there's
a parabola we have an equation for that
okay and so the equation is not only for
the shape but for the object that's
following the parabolic path
where is that object at one half of a
second at one second at two seconds has
it landed yet how many seconds is it
Airborne we know the complete trajectory
of that Parabola because I can write it
down
we have these equations okay then there
I am running
in a straight line at a constant speed
and I want my path through space which
is on the field okay I want my path
on the field to intersect this Parabola
moving through the air so that we arrive
at the same place at the same time
just think of that
that that's that's not a trivial using
you solve it with simultaneous equations
all right I don't remember that from
your ninth grade math all right when do
you learn simultaneously I forgot when
I think uh I went to Philadelphia Public
Schools
I think I'm gonna take that course next
year
you think about this and the guys in the
Outfield with his mitt he's not got any
calculations going on on a calculator on
a piece of paper this is all going off
in here this is intuitive but
also add into that I have done this so
many times I've also now got what I
would call in-game intelligence who's
pitching what pitcher they're going to
deliver and who's hitting what's their
go-to how's that going to come so I
might even before this wood hits the
ball I'll have already moved myself into
a certain position anticipating the
potential of this ball coming this is
all in-game intelligence and then
they'll adjust because they know once
that angle exit angle is is visible they
will move accordingly yeah and it's it's
just it's all what's going on in here
just brilliant well mostly what else you
also have to learn is if they hook or
slice the ball then the spin on the ball
makes it not entirely ballistic okay
there's an aerodynamic Force operating
so it'll hook depending if it's a
right-handed batter or left-handed
batter it'll hook left or slice right to
to borrow terms from golf and so you not
only have to run fast fast enough to be
where the ball would have been in a
purely ballistic trajectory you have to
then compensate for it yes the extra
move that's why you see these guys
running full force into the foul lines
and into the embankments because
depending on what was the left-handed
about or right-handed batter the ball
had extra sideways drift right to it
that's harder to get right and that'll
get almost everybody but if a
professional player and it even gets
professional players every now and then
and that is why what both of you said
the place hitters are the guys that are
so like Squirrely and and and difficult
to to play against because they don't
match up with that it's like oh we know
that this guy pulls left we know but the
place hitters are like yeah I'm going
this way now I see you guys shifted I'm
going the opposite direction yeah so so
my issue with that Chuck I wanna so
badly believe that okay but
and I sort of do
right but
if most of the time
you don't get a hit right who are you to
say that one time you did get a hit yeah
I meant that I meant that right is it
really meant to do that all the time if
you can't do that if 70 of the time you
walking home 75 of the time you're going
back to the Dugout after you saw 10
pitches then who am I to believe you
that you that you have any control at
all okay so all right someone explained
it to me after a while because they were
tired of hearing me rant about this and
they said you can swing in such a way
so that if you hit the ball it goes
where you want right right
that's how you that's how they they yeah
those are the guys like you know what
was his name I forget his name he used
to always get him was it Paul olaru
what's his name I think anyway but
there's guys that just like consistently
get on base and they're like contact
hitters they're not trying they're just
like I don't give a damn I'm just gonna
let the bat touch the ball and that's it
and then uh you know yeah but still 70
of the time they don't get on me so yeah
just to be clear
a hitter will have to read the field
because if the field is misplaced and he
doesn't read it and he does make the
contact and he hits it to where it's
overloaded he's screwing his chances up
so he's got to have some awareness I
agree all that's true but I'm making a
more pure physics
that any Fly ball that you can catch
you can you now occasionally if you're
really fast and you can run to it and
just wait for the ball to come into your
mid that can happen but for so many fly
balls they're running at just the rate
so that they're exactly and necessary
just so they're exactly when the ball
hits and they're generally not running
their fastest for most of those catches
they're running at the rate that their
brain like you said Gary that the brain
tells them is the right speed to be
where the ball is so that they're the
same place at the same time that that is
a simultaneous physics equation that you
do in physics 101 and and humans do it
in their head almost intuitively and I'm
just very proud of us for that yes
there's some people who are not
coordinated and may never be coordinated
but and they were never on the field to
begin with OR they were on the field
once and they were never invited back
but this this feature of the human mind
that I'm telling you about is so
widespread that I think it's something
inherent in just what it is to be human
I'm trying to figure out what
why what skill I'm sorry what task would
we have needed to develop this skill
because it would have to be something in
our evolutionary past okay suppose
suppose it's a it's your dinner
back when we were hunter-gatherers and
you have a spear and you are running to
intersect your dinner
you know that that's a good motivation
that's a good move but then but you we
have a spear so you don't have to be in
that exact spot but if you ran in a way
that you didn't close your distance to
it you died because you were not fed
yeah I mean I don't know if that's true
Chuck but I'm making that up as some
right explanation yeah no one said about
running towards the ball and sometimes
they don't run at their top speed but if
you because you don't have to and they
don't run to the ball oh by the way and
I've done this experiment with children
right if you do to your point Gary do
you learn this or is it intuitive is it
a sixth sense so if you take a small a
child a toddler and you roll a ball to
them
they will go to where they see the ball
is
not to where they project the ball will
be when they get there
and starting around six maybe or seven
from my test that I've done they will
begin to anticipate where the ball will
be factoring in the rate at which they
close in on the ball so they can get
there at the same time also factoring
then the uh that they've been hit in the
face with a ball many many times
misjudging where it will be Chuck don't
bring your childhood into the middle of
the
shower traumas you you will learn as an
athlete and I I love this and there's a
phrase I'm going to use
um just in a second one I'm playing
football soccer and it's don't let your
own speed beat you
so if you run too fast towards the sub
the the object that you're trying to get
then you're on speed defeats you yeah
any football in football they call that
over Pursuit and it's so interesting
yeah over Pursuit and it's something
that defensive uh players do and you're
right it's a detriment because they
anticipate the play being at Point a and
whoever it they're so quick to get to
that point but to play shifts in that
fraction of a second and now they're
standing there in the middle of nowhere
because if you get there quicker than
you need to you have to use energy to
slow down and that's it you wouldn't
have otherwise oh you missed your object
it's right it's speed with intelligence
yes and and it's being able to and this
comes from
just years of experience some people
have a better level of in-game
intelligence to begin with some people
get that through experience those people
who have a higher level get that
experience they get even better here's a
question I have not successfully
answered for myself and I've taken this
to some cyber metric people and they
scratch their head a bit so here it is
and you think I have the answer yeah
if you have performed professionally
okay on a soccer field okay I'll have a
go yeah okay
if you are fast
and you play in the Outfield yeah you're
fast
do you make more or fewer spectacular
catches
I'm going to say fewer but this is
so fast
you're getting there to make it look
easy if I never show up on the Highlight
wheel
it means I'm faster than everyone else
who did all right
because I'm standing there waiting for
the ball so the other the other side of
that is my speed my I'll call it
electric speed because I'm bigging
myself up allows me to cover more of the
Outfield
right the ball that the slower athlete
can't get I'll get and I'll get that
that highlight real catch Time After
Time After Time because that's the
rebuttal Chuck exactly what Gary said
perimeter right my perimeter is bigger
is bigger than yours is if I run faster
than you yeah you know what we call that
you know we call that right we call that
an outfield hog okay
left field
in center field because I had it I said
I got it what kind of I got it don't you
understand this is not baggage hour from
your little league trauma okay
so for me those two competing facts have
prevented me from settling on whether my
speed with my bigger perimeter means
there will always be the ball that I
will shoestring catch and I'll simply
make more outs I'll perform more outs
than someone who's shorter and that but
yet we'll both be on the highlight my
personal jury is still out on that I
wonder if we solve mathematically I
might try that my personal jury is keep
your stats on your side of the field
okay center field is mine
all right so three cheers for the human
mind I brain hand coordination and the
fact that we can do what would otherwise
take the solutions of simultaneous
equations of uh
and graph paper
to figure out amazing
all right good to be human yes great
Chuck are you agree Gary uh occasionally
for cats and crap yeah yeah
occasionally occasionally I Chuck Gary
that's all the time we have for this one
yeah yeah but it was I was a good one I
think it makes you feel good Being Human
that that that's yeah we needed some of
that needed a pat on the back now every
now and then I I'll Pat the species
all right let's face it we still
sucking words
all right it's been another Star Talk
explainer the sports edition Edition
Neil deGrasse Tyson keep looking up
foreign